It is quite amazing. I mean, usually,
so this is a very big collaboration of people and usually word leaks out
somewhere. The sort of analogous thing that happened, not that long ago,
where the first results about gravitational waves and there the world kind of
nods and winks going on. And if you knew the right people,
then you could probably get a little bit of an inside track.
This has been absolutely nothing. They really kept it completely under wraps.
The data they're going to be presenting today was actually taken in 2017.
So they've been analyzing for the last couple of years is kind of the nature of
this data. It is incredibly complex.
So actually getting it to a point where you go from the raw data to something
that looks like an impressive in image is a lot of work. Um, and they,
so that would have taken most of the last couple of years, but, uh,
at this point they must know that they've got something good.
So this thing called the event horizon is kind of that point of no return.
It's the point where you can not even light can no longer escape from,
from the region around a black hole.
The region we would hope to see today is a bit bigger than that.
It's probably about two or three times that event horizon size. Um,
really because,
well it's because of the distorting effects are so strong because what we're
actually going to see is sort of light from around the black hole radio wave
light. Um, and that radio wave light is originating a little bit further away.
And also this you've got this massive object in the case of the one in the
middle of the Milky way. It's about 4 million times the mass of the sun,
which really means that the poles of light you think about light traveling in
straight lines,
but because the gravitational field is so intense and the space-time is so
curved, the light actually travels in very bent,
pause technique they're using is the thing called very long baseline
interferometry. So the object that they're trying to resolve the size of this,
the event horizon is about 30 times the radius of the sun.
So it's absolutely tiny at the distance of the galactic center. Um, and, uh,
the region that they're trying to see is a bit bigger than that,
but it's still absolutely tiny. The,
the analogy that's been drawn is it's like trying to take a picture of a golf
ball on the moon. Okay.
So the technique and the technique they using really involves making the
diameter of the telescope bigger and bigger.
And so one thing you can do is instead of having a single telescope,
you'd have multiple telescopes,
and then as you move them further and further apart,
the sharpness of the image increases because of the,
the ultimate sharpness is limited by the distance between your two most distant
parts of your telescope. In the technique they're using,
they're actually recording the data on different radio telescopes,
all around the world. So these enormous it's,
the diameter of the earth is the diameter of the telescope they're using.
But then the tricky part is then having collected all that data,
you then have to combine it all together. And that's this,
the technique that they're using this thing called very long baseline
interferometry in both taking all that signal, um, and actually is.
So they collect so much data.
It's not something you can just transfer over the internet.
They actually end up recording the data on hard drives shipping,
the hard drives to a place where you can kind of correlate all that data
together and combining the information from the telescopes to extract an image
from it. So the trouble is everyone has in their mind, the,
the movie interstellar, right?
Because they had the most amazing graphics of what one of these supermassive
black holes would look like. Um, and they were actually, you know,
they had real physicists involved in it.
There was actually lots of serious general relativistic calculations went into
making those, uh,
those graphics for the movie because the trouble is they could do that at
whatever resolution they wanted really limited by the resolution that we can
achieve with the wavelengths that we have with the diameter of the earth that we
have, which really means that you're not going to see those incredibly pin sharp
images. The whole thing is going to be a bit blurry. Um,
but hopefully it's going to be a blurry image of something really exciting and a
blurry image of something really exciting is probably pretty exciting itself.
There was one of the things I mentioned,
which is that there's another candidate out there they're actually observed two
objects. So they are observed the objects in the middle of the,
of the Milky way, um, which is this black hole of about 4 million times,
the mass of the, of the sun. Uh,
they also were looking at the black hole in the middle of a much bigger galaxy
MSCI, 87 in the middle of the Virgo cluster, um,
which is several thousand times further away. So actually the, the,
the quality of the images will be several thousand times poorer because you're
trying to look at something further away. So everything's much smaller,
but the black hole in the middle of MSCI,
87 is several thousand times bigger than the black hole in the middle of the
Milky way. And it turns out that, uh, uh,
event horizon size scales with the mass of the, of the black hole.
So if you've got a black hole, which is a couple of thousand times bigger, uh,
in mass than its its event,
horizon will be a couple of thousand times bigger as well.
So the whole thing scales up in size.
So it turns out the ultimate sharpness of the image that they will get from the
black hole in the middle of MSCI. 87 is about the same as from the Milky way.
Um, and it's a bit of a toss up, which one's going to make the nicer pictures.
I think my bet is still on the Milky way.
Cause it's actually works that when you do the calculations, it works out,
you end up with slightly sharper images for the Milky way,
but there's not much in it.
Yeah. Did you bring up
that this is
[inaudible] and this is the first step
you can capture. These dimensions are not sufficient.
If you want to know what net black on it looks.
Um, so for, from our chatting before the press conference,
I was wrong and I was raped. Right.
I was wrong because I picked the wrong black hole.
I said they were looking at two,
the one at the middle of the Milky way and the one in MSCI 87.
And I thought they'd be more likely to find something about how one, um,
but it turns out that this is the one they got the result from today's
announcement was pretty special actually,
because I've been working on black holes myself for 20 years.
I did my PhD in black holes.
I've been working on ever since in one form or another.
So today it feels like quite profound day. Um, and to make it even more special,
I was watching the press release downstairs, uh,
with my six year old son and he had toy black hole
with him and he was sitting there comparing it with a finger on the screen.
And it does look more or less as we were talking about before that there is this
kind of ring of fire effect, um, that there are more particularly,
you're kind of not seeing any light from the middle there.
And it really is just down to this effect that the light is being so bent by
this black hole, somewhere in the middle there,
that the light you're seeing kind of coming out around the sides is actually
you're being emitted around the back of the black hole and being bent right
round.
So I've been bent by 90 degrees and more to head towards us and into our line of
sight. And that really is sort of the definition of strong gravity right.
Late to the party here. It is currently, uh,
two 40 Nottingham time and it's been half an hour since the results were
released. Um, in that time I've been interviewing prospective undergraduates.
Um,
and I actually made them sit down and watch the press release up until the point
where we saw the image of the black hole. And then I,
I thought we better get on with the business of the interviews.
Yes, it looks, it looks like our toy black hole. Um,
but the real black hole doesn't have eyes and the real black hole,
isn't this cute cuddly as well. And he said, my toy black hole,
it doesn't have the ring of fire around it.
We know that light gets bent by gravity.
It has been known for actually almost exactly a hundred years.
The first measurements of this effect were made almost exactly a hundred years
ago. Um,
when they were looking at what happens during a total eclipse of the sun,
where stars near the sun, the position of the star shifts a little bit,
just because the light from those stars is being bent a tiny bit by the, uh,
by the gravity of the sun.
So we've known about this effect in kind of that weak gravity limits that things
like can get bent a tiny bit by something as massive as the sun.
Now we're talking about light getting bent through 90 degrees and more,
and now you're talking about really, really strong gravitational fields.
So that gets us very much into that Einstein and of general relativity.
If you were just presented with a picture like that and say, what's going on,
you could come up with many explanations as to what it was that there's a,
there was a cosmic donut out there in space,
or there's a sphere and you're seeing the ages of a sphere or whatever.
You know, there are lots of ways you could explain.
There are many things in space that looked like rings, but the thing is here.
They said, okay. So we think that general relativity is right.
And we think there's a massive black hole in the middle of these galaxy.
And we think that it's got a lot of this sort of radio emitting material around
it. What would we expect to see if those things were the truth?
And then they predicted this is what you want to see pretty much.
And then you go out and take the picture and there it is.
And then so in some sense, that's the best proof the river is,
is when you actually predict something before you go and see it. Um,
and so I think this, in that sense,
this probably is the best evidence there has ever been for a supermassive black
hole in the middle of a galaxy. Okay.
There are lots of ways that you can get those kinds of asymmetries.
The most likely I think, uh,
is that what's actually happening is that the material is rotating. It's not,
it's not just sort of uniformly spread around there.
It's actually spinning around because we know further out there's a disc of
material, which is spinning around.
So the stuff we're staying close to the black hole is probably in a row with a
turbulent messy way, still rotating around.
And what happens is the bit that's coming toward,
you gets a big boost in energy. There's this thing called the Doppler effect.
And in lights, the way,
one of the ways that manifests itself is that the light gets a lot brighter.
There's a lot more energy in it, whereas the stuff that's going away from you,
you see it a lower energy. And so you basically see it as fainter.
And so I think that asymmetry we're seeing there is just to do with the rotation
of material around the black hole. I mean,
there was a lot of structure there as well.
It looks like there's something that points out this way as well,
which I'm kind of intrigued by. And again,
one of the things that might be expected as you might expect,
jets of material to be flying out of the black hole, um,
and the material would probably be rotating around those jets of material.
So it sort of fits together. But again, that's kind of down near the,
the limits of what you can actually see on an image like that.
This I really, this is just my very first reaction to it. Um,
so I am really looking forward to reading about the science.
That's come out of this about whether the structures that I'm seeing in the
background here are real and what they mean. Um,
and just how these predictions match up, not just on a qualitative level,
but on a quantitative level to the data that's actually been gathered.
I mean,
the other thing that you sort of have to take your hats off to the people
involved in this experiment,
because you have to bear in mind the technique they're using via BI.
It's not just like taking a picture with a camera.
You've got to take all these data from all the different radio telescopes,
combine them all together. And from that.
So basically you take sort of every pair of radio telescopes,
and you get a bit of information from the sort of the phase delay,
the difference in the signal between each pair.
And each of those gives you a little bit of a picture,
but actually you don't have the whole picture.
And it is it's essentially because, you know, if you've got a regular camera,
you're kind of got your lens or your mirror,
if it's a telescope is sort of filling the entire aperture in this case,
you've just got a few dishes sort of scattered within your aperture.
That means there's a lot of missing information,
which means that you then have to kind of reconstruct that missing information.
And there are actually there isn't generally a unique solution to this.
So there is a little bit of kind of prejudice that goes into this that says,
because you can, you know,
there are many different images you could reconstruct from those data.
Most of them look completely ridiculous.
And so you can sort of throw them out on the basis that they look on physical,
that they they're just very noisy or they just don't match what you'd expect
from a real astronomical object. Um, and so the sort of,
a lot of processing that has to go in to turning this data into an image now
what's going to happen over time is a more and more dishes get added to this
network of telescopes. So you have more and more pairs of telescopes,
which gives you more and more information. So as time goes on,
they're going to be repeating these experiments with more and more information.
So the images will get better and better,
and there'll be less of that kind of interpolation of figuring out the missing
data, just because there'll be less missing data. Um, but for the moment,
there's a lot of work that has to go into turning, uh,
the raw data into an image like this. And so that's,
I think fundamentally the reason why it's taken all the time from when they took
the data two years ago to now to actually produce an image this from the data
they collected. So there's talk about putting radio telescopes into space,
because remember what dictates the sharpness of the image is how far apart your
most distant parts of your telescope,
or if you could put your telescopes into orbit,
if you could put one of them on the moon,
if you could put them all into orbit around the sun, then in principle,
you can make longer and longer baselines. There's not a lot to this picture.
Is there really, it's like, you know, it's a ring with a hole in the middle,
but actually I think that's absolutely astounding. How amazing is that, that,
that, you know, millions of light years away,
you can actually see a black hole in another galaxy down to the scale. I mean,
the black hole, remember the, the black region in the middle,
it's about three times the ultimate size of the black hole itself.
So the black hole itself is actually not much smaller than this.
We really are getting right down into that strong gravity regime right next to
the event, horizon of a black hole, uh,
exceeded my expectations with our simulations of what this might look like.
And they look more or less exactly like this,
but I thought all with scattering of light and instrumental effects and noise,
you know, they'll be lucky to get it,
to get the prediction as accurately as that, but it looks bang on.
So it's pretty, pretty special. So we,
we're seeing this radio synchrotron radiation from the immediate vicinity of a
black hole,
and you can see the black hole itself shadowing the light so you
can see its influence. Um, it's pretty special. Yeah.
The people will be analyzing these data for years to come. I think so. Um,
it feels like it doesn't feel like a real breakthrough. Yeah. Well, I mean,
so remember, you're looking at radio waves here,
so you can actually make this any color you want it to be fundamentally. Um,
and they've clearly just picked something which looked nice. You know,
you could perfectly well have done it in black and white or, you know,
because these are what you're really looking at here. A millimeter waves,
not optical light at all. So yes, there are,
there is a certain matter of aesthetics as to what color you end up reproducing
these images in, and it makes a big difference.
That's the other interesting thing that NASA employees, uh,
graphic designers who know what looks really nice because you do have that
degree of freedom because it is all about how you present the data.
And you know, it's not, there's no dishonesty here in that.
The reason I write color. Cause as I say, these are radio waves, radio waves,
aren't either blue or green they're radio waves.
So actually you really can pick whatever color looks nicest. Yeah.
For galaxy is the size of a football.
The supermassive black hole in the nucleus is the size of a hydrogen atom.
So that absolutely tiny, but the energy they can produce is,
and they can more than enough to blow the galaxy to bits many times over.
So they, uh, understanding the link between these supermassive black holes,
like the one they found, they,
they announced today and the broader galaxies that they're embedded in.
I think that's a really key issue for me personally.
It's an area I work on and how the galaxies form, how do they switch offs?
Forming stars, black holes may play a role.
And now we know that the really old black holes are there.
So we knew that before, but we've got an actual image of one for the first time.
So there's been loads of evidence for black holes,
but no actual image to take a picture of one.
So it's pretty special.
We've made quite a few.
The video is about black holes. Over the years,
I'm going to put a link in the video description and here on the screen,
also our astronomy channel, deep sky videos.
We've got a video all about M 87 already on there.
So if you want to find out more about mad seven again,
links on the screen video description.